it was that girl that was licking [__]
off Jake's fingers Sky Bree yo Skype I
was talking about her on the Pod that
was crazy that was wild bro that's one
of Adam's uh Adams the girl that worked
at Target yeah yeah yeah she's been like
did she blow up the way you guys
the adult film world didn't I say that
she was gonna blow the [__] up yeah I
all said that I didn't think that it was
that talented yeah I think she was like
2022 PornHub released their data I think
she was like top 14 is what my friend
told me she's gonna be number one she's
gonna be number one very soon what's
crazy blow up in porn and only fans at
the same time like I think she's like
over a million dollars a month something
crazy doing well I guess only fans is uh
yeah shout out to Jake yo I mean but
yeah as well big day for the Paul
Brothers basically yo basically like
she said that Jake threw his fingers in
a girl's [__] there was doodoo on it
and she sucked it off
yeah I was a writer I wouldn't tell
people that though but also doesn't that
incriminate no if you're her you would
yeah shorty it just makes you like as if
you've got doodoo in your [__] that's
normal like you can't be mad at someone
for having doodle in their [__] but
she's also got to tell him like Hey by
the way I'm not coming I didn't I didn't
get a I didn't get an end she didn't say
the timing
starting out I mean that's a wild thing
to do bro yeah you know you got to take
that to the grave no we're out of here
I don't know if is that something guys
like like I'm not turned on by that at
all I think if you I think down for
whatever yeah everybody's into it I
think a porn star that's down for
whatever is guys are going to be into
that confidence thing you know what I
mean you're a boomer dude you're a boom
or whatever like spitting to come back
in like I don't like that [__]
people like Usher whoa whoa
but don't
spit it out once yeah my dick that [__]
got to be far away from me
I agree it leaves I don't think you know
what he's saying I know what he's saying
yeah other girls mouth whatever I don't
want to see that [__] if
yeah that's so I could stay in the [__]
long enough
I gotta stay in the [__] long enough
what if I'm on my back and I'm staying
in the [__]
and then you come on your own stomach
that's so weird though yeah because you
could point it the other way you could
just go out yeah my own stomach really
ain't that bad but once it's on someone
else and then comes back on me that's
not yours anymore that's a gift don't
worry gift it to me don't you give me a
gift don't read gifts yeah there's no
re-gifting actually that's a good point
it's like when you put food the moment
it touches the garbage can it's garbage
yeah it could be something fresh but the
moment it passes that seal yeah yeah you
can't take nothing out the [__]
garbage y'all have actually never eaten
out of the garbage before
she's a sick [__] bro
you really
weird [__] but you've worn clothes over
in the hamper that's different bro what
are you even saying it's Shades
that's them Florida you've even come off
the ground right like I'm saying it's
Shades it's been less than five seconds
yeah five seconds remember it's all
shades that is crazy Shades bro yeah I
don't know about this story man
I'm subscribing I'm unsubscribed from
the of
um sweater make it look better
next video